okay good morning everyone uh we are
very happy to have Hamza astania's
office because she will talk on uh
border testing
um
hi everyone uh thanks for coming I know
it's crazy early in the morning but I
came from the East Coast so I'm feeling
pretty good uh this is doing work with
uh kimon dracopoulos who will actually
talk about this in two weeks in the data
driven Workshop which is probably going
to be better so I encourage you to go
check that out uh Vishal Gupta from USC
uh John lacha Giannis who is actually a
an entrepreneur who was a software
architect for this tool that we were
deploying and then the rest of the
co-authors are actually members of the
Greek covid-19 task force uh so they
were obviously instrumental for us to
understand the epidemiologist side and
also like the policy side for getting
this deployed
so this works okay uh just to kind of
set the backdrop a little bit uh we got
involved in this project in kind of
early 2020. uh so early 2022 is when we
were all finding out about covet for the
first time uh so a lot of countries kind
of went down it went into lockdown so
Greece actually went into lockdowns of
different stringency levels between
March to May 2020 uh but tourism is
actually a 25 of their GDP so staying in
lockdown was uh had pretty harsh
Economic Consequences as they were going
to that first summer like tourist season
of 2020. uh and so they decided that
they were actually going to open their
borders uh on July 1st 2020 uh for
non-essential travel so basically
letting people come in to you know spend
money and kind of keep the economy up
and running but then of course the flip
side of this coin is a public health
consequences of this right so now you
might be very worried that you were
letting in a lot of infected and
asymptomatic Travelers into the country
they're going to be partying on beaches
and clubs and you know they might be
infecting other people in the population
and that could lead to a Public Health
crisis so ideally what you would do is
you would just uh test every single
person who's coming into the country at
the border if they test positive you
tell them hey you got a quarantine
please don't party if they test negative
you know you say go crazy spend as much
money as you can while you're here our
economy needs it right uh but
unfortunately at this time people were
very reliant on PCR testing so we didn't
have rapid testing kits of reasonable
accuracy yet uh npcr testing supply
chains were very strained uh so it was
very difficult to expand capacity uh
pretty much impossible and so you could
only test
um a small set of Travelers uh so what
we decided to try and do uh is to try
and closer why do you call it the
conservative approach
uh like conservative from a public
health perspective like they had
followed uh they had
there's a trade-off here about having
like uh uh you know Public Health versus
economic activity right so they were
conservative in the sense that they were
limiting infections originally by going
into lockdown uh that were fairly
stringent and then that limited economic
activity but that wasn't sustainable as
like the tourist season was approaching
yes so China is like a whole other level
I mean people most people would say that
China's approach has been heavily
conservative yeah yeah I mean they
limited uh activity to the point that
people weren't allowed to leave their
homes I don't think that would fly
anywhere else yeah still I don't
understand the word conservative what
would be the opposite Sweden so what
we're doing now
approaches
what would you call the opposite of
conservative not having any lockdown
oh yeah
uh so I think Spain also so every place
that went on lockdown basically said I
do have to ask for the microphone if you
want to ask me a question like that
sorry
I was going to say so your definition of
conservative approach is every location
on planet Earth that went on lockdown
Community lockdown is conservative if
people have to stay home yeah too much
into that that's just a curious
background uh that is not what they
continued doing they opened their
borders and we're trying to like uh you
know have this nice trade-off between
having free activity but then also you
know trying to keep the infections under
like certain safety level uh but yeah at
this point I guess like in this context
we would refer to any place that had
like a stringent lockdown so limiting
people's mobility and activity to like
reduce infections you see I think people
are confused because in the U.S
conservative means you don't even
believe that the virus exists yeah sorry
so probably not the best usage of the
term
watching yeah other questions or
comments I did not expect to spend this
much time on this flight
okay I will I will try to tame the
audience no no this is great that keeps
me awake so
um so the solution we proposed is a tool
called Ava so this is basically a
platform it's a real-time data-driven
system that allocates a limited testing
resources that we have with PCR testing
supply chains uh to kind of get the most
bang for our buck uh so if you know if
you can't test everyone ideally you
would test people who are most likely to
test positive with the hope that you
will find and catch the most infections
and get them to quarantine right so that
would be the safest approach given a
limited testing budget and so primarily
what Ava does is it basically uses
machine learning to recommend who to
test
um because this was like a fairly large
like financial and Technical investment
from the government like it was also
used to inform like some Downstream
decision decisions so for one thing is
that um the office of the Prime Minister
would basically like monitor like the
infection risk of different countries
and if one place looked like it was
getting too risky uh they would
basically get graylisted so that means
that uh they have to any arrival has to
produce within the last 72 hours a
negative pre-pcr test
um showing that you know they were
actually testing negative this was very
difficult to actually do because PCR
testing resources were very limited
um and so like this would basically this
is basically like a hammer like a Rivals
would tank after country risk gray
listed of course infection risk would
also change so it's not an ideal
decision to make it also has various
political consequences so this is not
something we optimized for but it was
something that used the estimates for
and it also offered various like
interpretable insights to the Greek
government in the sense that
um they were they would use these risk
estimates to figure out like where they
should deploy like ad hoc mobile testing
teams or social distancing rules and so
on
questions
cool uh so let me just overview a little
bit so we get about 30 to 100 000
passengers who arrived every day to
Greece uh during the summer of 2020 so
this is actually much lower than like
regular tourist Seasons because it's the
pandemic
um and they arrived through 40 different
points of Entry so it could be like by a
boat by uh land or by air but mostly by
air uh 24 hours prior to travel families
fill out something called a passenger
locator form so this basically serves to
collect various features like where
they're coming from their origin
location some demographic information
and then some information that's used by
the contact tracing teams in case they
test positive the primary feature we
ended up using that was actually
predictive was the origin location so
where they're flying in from so this is
a gdpr compliant feature that actually
was like pretty predictive of how risky
you are of testing positive at the
airport uh so all of this gets fed into
our system Ava uh and like I said
unfortunately the testing capacity is
quite Limited it so most people don't
get tested about 7 500 people per day
would actually get a QR code to get
tested yes
travel without
testing first yeah all of these almost
most of these people would travel
oh yes
people could get on a plane without
testing because usually in that summer
you needed a negative test to award a
plane right I think I don't think people
needed a negative test yeah
I think that's what she called gray
listing so if you needed to test to
board a plane you were greylists that in
Greece didn't want all the tourists
parting so that didn't do that
so during the summer yeah that's great
uh during the summer we graylisted or
the office of the Prime Minister agree
listed about 10 countries uh I think the
testing requirements like sha like shot
up for certain countries like the US had
one for a while about coming back to the
country at this point it was very
difficult to get a test like early 2020
right
um and the U.S Americans for example
weren't even allowed to go into the EU
so it's sort of a different time
what do you call American blacklisted or
crazy yeah
yeah so realistic means you can go in
this this test black Mister list that
you just can't go in yeah so
blacklisting I decided by the EU at the
EU level so a lot of countries that
weren't allowed into the
gray listing
they're in the allowed list of countries
in the U but then Greece decides that uh
they need to produce extra documentation
like a negative PCR protest
foreign
so about 68 000 of these people will get
a QR code from us saying that they
should get tested uh so they jump behind
one of these curtains like this is at
the airport uh to get their swap taken
uh their QR code gets scanned and it
gets linked to their sample that gets
put on some truck which gets uh shipped
off to a lab uh and basically we had
contracts or agreements with uh 32
different Labs saying that they would
submit uh all their results to back to
the database with the at most a two-day
delay right
uh and so that information will go back
into Ava where we uh which we use to
update our predictive models uh to make
the next set of test allocations so I
have a question so the PCR test you
could they are sort of
did that tell you the number of Cycles
also or just the positive or negative
uh just positive or negative yeah
because I think in the EU that would
actually report the numbers I mean they
would in the US you can't even get the
number of Cycles whereas in Europe you
usually could get them and the more
Cycles you need the lower your infection
risks but you didn't learn those
quantitative quantitative measures well
there was a fairly standardized process
no they used pooling for testing so
pools of five
but only binary answers okay
so um
before the test come result comes back
you just let the visitor in like you're
not using it to decide if the visitor
can go in or not I think technically
they were supposed to kind of isolate
for the first two days uh we don't know
that anyone did
but yeah technically they're supposed to
like wait for their result to come back
but
you know it's very hard to kind of
monitor these things especially with
gdpr you know it's not Singapore where
you can track their cell phone or
something
um cool so you guys probably already
know this but there's positive feedback
loop here it's kind of critical to
making Ava work well basically you know
we're actively collecting new data at
the border on every type of Passenger
who might come in uh and that lets us
stay agile in responding to how the
epidemic risk is evolving over time in
different parts of the world so it's
like a highly non-stationary process uh
and so kind of having this active
feedback loop is sort of is very
important to be able to make good
testing decisions and following those
spikes closely to you know preserve
Public Health
um so this is a fairly large scale
operation like I said we scaled 40
points of Entry there were like 400
medical professionals and 300 border
agents there were 32 Labs uh there were
a number of dashboards that we designed
to like basically communicate this
information uh and there were constant
meetings uh there's kimon with the Greek
Prime Minister of Mr Takis like kind of
translating this into policy
recommendations he's very proud of this
picture
um but so this was sort of like uh uh
there were a lot of people sort of
involved in making sure that uh the
estimates that we were getting were
actually being integrated in a
reasonable way
um so let me just go over the objective
like the mathematical objective first so
like uh like I mentioned the most
predictive feature that we had was the
origin location of passengers so this is
a very high dimensional but categorical
variable so you can think of segmenting
passengers into kind of discrete types
uh so I'll talk a little bit about how
we deal with the high dimensionality
later but for now just think about it as
like maybe country level right so we
have like Americans but not really
because America was blacklisted but you
know
um so for every type of Passenger we
have a test outcome that we model as a
Bernoulli random variable with some
extent expected probability of testing
positive RK of T so you'll notice that
it depends both on the type K as well as
a Time step t uh because again it was a
very uh non-stationary process right so
like a place can Spike and then go back
down you know and risk you know about a
week later
and importantly RK of T is unknown the
main decision that we're making is how
many passengers to test the nkef so how
many passengers to test on a given day T
of type K at entry e so there are 40
different points of Entry you can't
really move your testing budget around
uh easily right uh so that means our
objective if we want to maximize the
expected number of infections caught is
actually really simple it's a number of
people who are testing times the
probability that they will test positive
uh summed over all the entries all the
types and all the days in the summer
right so you can already see like if we
knew our kft this is a pretty trivial
problem I'm just going to allocate all
my testing budget to the riskiest
passengers so people who have the
highest RK of t uh until I run out of
testing budget right so this is what
we're saying about getting the most bang
for our buck we want to test the people
we want to aggressively trust people who
have a higher likelihood of testing
positive but of course the kicker is
that we don't know rtft and and worse
our estimate our cat kfd kind of depends
on the testing allocations we made in
the previous time period right so if we
don't test any Spanish passengers uh for
you know two weeks we're not going to
have any data to estimate our hat TFT so
they do become super risky like that's a
big blind spot in our algorithm we
wouldn't even know right
right uh and then these are the
constraints we basically have to respect
the testing budget constraint at each
point of entry on each day so we don't
want to overload Labs because then they
won't be able to satisfy our two-day
guarantee uh and then we also um I'll
talk about this later also but like
arrivals are not kind of uniformly
spread across points of Entry right like
certain types of people might be more
likely to show up at certain ports uh so
you have to make sure that there's a
match there too but I'll kind of get to
that later yeah inside information like
use data from Britain and British
Travelers yeah so we actually tried
really hard I'm somewhere you can repeat
the questions oh yes sorry
um so Elon asks uh can we use side
information like information about uh
testing results from Britain for example
to
um make our estimates better
um so first of all we need like kind of
a unified source of information so we
used uh we looked at this like one our
world in data where people were
reporting like every country's like
testing rates like uh cases estimated
cases and debts uh surprisingly we found
that it had no signal about the risk of
people showing up in Greece and I'll
talk about this later like the results
are kind of surprising to us at least uh
there's a lot of reasons like one is
that there's like a population mismatch
like the people they're testing are
typically like older like symptomatic
like risky individuals whereas the
people coming to Greece on vacation in
early 2020 or not those people uh but
also there's a lot of censoring
depending on a country's testing
resources we don't have visibility into
that so um it turned out that for us
like we trained a bunch of models I'll
show you later they got like 0.5 a URC
so there was no signal but that's an
excellent question that was our prior
too
yes
it seems like your wrist does not depend
on the point of entry so the answer
point doesn't really play a big role
except that you cannot test more than
arrive at the entry of course but yeah
okay that's more important than the eat
yes yes so there is no no you have to
repeat the question
I'm so bad at this
um so the question was our estimate
estimates RK of T we've assumed that I
don't depend on the entry point uh so
I'll say two things so first of all yes
that is so the assumption is that the
primary feature we're using
um to predict someone's uh risk is where
they're coming from not necessarily the
entry point they're coming into uh this
is sort of a bias variance trade-off
issue because if we actually like the
data I'll talk about later already has
like very very high variance because
very imbalanced outcomes very high
dimensional categorical features so we
further split it by entry point uh we
wouldn't be able to get a signal so you
can think of this as we're injecting a
little bit of bias to get a variance
reduction by pulling across points of
Entry uh but mainly all the results I'll
report use um uh off like inverse
propensity weighting which is model
agnostic so even if this model is like
somewhat misclassified we'll still get
an accurate uh counterfactual
yes
and you assume that the uh these rates
are exogenous right like you're not the
policy decisions are not going to impact
the arrivals yeah yep
um and we have no reason to believe that
um you know like gracious local airplane
like border testing policy is going to
affect the risk of future arrivals from
like the UK or something so you and
you're not worried that there's a rumor
nobody just at the Harvard Essence let's
just go all in there because then we can
get it
yeah that's the start of the subject so
I'll also say I think like the testing
budgets by entry point were you know not
public so this is not something that
people should be able to figure out
right
but yeah that's the assumption
other thoughts so are you adjusting for
sensitivity and specificity are we
adjusting prices
so one really nice thing about losing
the abandoned arms is that uh every
location is using the same test right so
we have a fair comparison like uh they
all have the same sensitivity and
specificity uh and so if we're ranking
like two different countries uh if an
Apples to Apples comparison right like
we're not interested in the actual risk
we're interested in the cardinality so
all I want to say is if I give like 100
tests to Spanish Travelers and 100
tested German Travelers who will have
kind of more risk right
so as long as the test has the same
properties like we don't need to adjust
for that for our purposes
oh so these were PCR yes so the
more pretty accurate tests we didn't
have rapid tests here
for this formulation like
that Journey okay because um we're
estimating our PFT with the same kind of
and that's fine right as long as
they all have the same voice if some
entries had worse sensitivity and
specificity that would be a concern but
that's not the case
so of course the countries just because
of the weather because of you know
various other external factors who may
have a little bit of variation in the
way in which this tester administered
for instance we're not looking at
Country steps these are all greases
tests
sorry that was the point so like all the
tests are the same because we are
administering all the tests
but definitely if people are coming in
with their own test outcomes this kind
of goes back to you one point a little
bit it would have been hard to
incorporate information from other
people's desks because they come with
different yeah so there's been
tremendous amount of research that sort
of indicates that depending how you get
calibrate some of these measurements you
may have very different results and it
might not be compared so I guess this is
not a problem in your particular right
because we're like using the same labs
and like the same standardized uh
protocols like for example all the group
sizes were also the same like you know
that uh the hope is that there is
sorry to have to ask you a follow-up
question
no sorry to have to ask you a follow-up
question
on the specificity and sensitivity of
the Greg asked so if I'm infected today
okay and I arrive in Athens today okay
the chances are all the tests will not
detect me as positive because it depends
on the right of the Lord and all of that
so I'm not really so unless it's like a
DNA type of test that can detect and
even when you have very little amount of
money this the the efficacy of the
testing is compromising saying that when
it was called when we know asymptomatic
and pre-symptomatic are the main drivers
of the epidemic right and and we're not
able to detect them because the tests
are not able to detect someone who just
got infected today yesterday so you let
them into the country and then three
days later they are highly infectious
yeah that is actually exactly right so
that was one of the reasons like so well
when we started we were thinking like
should we include like the flight
information right uh so because people
could have gotten infected on the plane
and you're right like if they got in
fact on the plane we wouldn't be able to
detect it at the airport anyway so you
should not think of this as a way to get
all of the infections you should think
of this as a way that if I constrained
you to say you can do some testing at
the airport how can you best kind of
maximize Public Health right uh so
there's a lot of logistical constraints
here yeah
uh but absolutely yeah
other thoughts I think you should try to
you should let her go through her slides
okay so I'm gonna start off talking
about the test allocation algorithm so
uh there's an expiration exploitation
trade-off here as you have probably
figured out uh so on one hand you want
to test enough passengers of every type
to kind of do surveillance right so that
you know whether or not they're risky
you don't have blind spots this is also
useful for like grade listing decisions
so we can tell the office of the Prime
Minister hey this is malta's risk uh
whereas if you did like random testing
you might not have allocated any tests
to like a tiny country like Malta
um and the other side of the coin of
course is that I'm interested in
exploitation so I want to actually use
these estimates to test arrivals from
the riskiest types you know aggressively
test them so I can find and quarantine
the most positive cases uh and this is a
very well studied problem you can use
you know upper confidence down Thompson
sampling kittens and decks we actually
built off of a and kittens index-based
policy because we wanted to try and get
those leading constants right uh but in
kind of bad tests you could have used
anything they're all kind of same up to
tuning right
right
um so just to illustrate what this would
look like in a classical Band-Aid like
imagine that uh we just have two types
of people uh Spanish Travelers and
German Travelers this is a fake example
um just for illustration uh so here I
have a point estimate for risk and I
also have a 95 confidence interval so it
looks like maybe Spanish Travelers are
riskier than German Travelers but I
really don't know because I have so much
uncertainty around my German Travelers
uh and so what a typical banded
algorithm would do here is first we
would do an exploration test so we
allocate a test to a German traveler we
you know swap them uh we get the test
result back we update our posterior so
now we're like pretty sure Spanish
Travelers are riskier than German
Travelers because I got information my
confidence interval shrunk my point
estimate shifted a little bit right so
now uh typically a banded algorithm will
move on to exploitation uh so we'll
allocate a test to Spanish Travelers uh
we again update our posterior and we
kind of continue right this is how kind
of any branded algorithm would work in
this setting
uh we use this optimistic institex
because I think I'm running late I will
skip it but basically it's an
index-based policy you compute an index
and you pick the arm with the highest
index you can also think of UCB as an
index-based policy of a mean plus like
some sort of standard deviation
okay so there's a couple of challenges
here that you probably noticed so first
of all
um the estimates that we have are highly
non-stationary right so we don't want to
be making uh decisions about who to test
using like a month old data uh so we
asked the epidemiologist on our team and
they kind of said like two weeks
probably seems like a reasonable window
uh they were actually remarkably close
so we did like a back test to minimize
like you know Auto sample error and 10
days is actually kind of the optimal
window so they were very close uh so
basically this was easy we just
discarded any testing results that were
over two weeks old in terms of computing
our estimates uh but where the problem
start is like when you have to think
about batch decision making and kind of
delayed feedback uh so it's not like the
little picture I showed you in the sense
that you know I conduct a test on you I
immediately get the results back right
so what actually happens is we get the
entire passenger manifest at the start
of the day and then we make all our
testing allocations for that day so it's
not you know real time time changing
what the decisions are but even if we
could it wouldn't be that useful because
we have delayed feedback right so I
don't get the result back right away
someone puts it on a truck and then it
gets shipped to the lab and then you
know the lab has to process it and then
we get it back like two days later right
so you said you did pulled testing right
so you so if one of them was positive
did you then have the original test so
you could find out who it was or what
you know if a mixture of one Japanese
one German one
Spanish and of what you pulled by
nationality how did you deal with it
yeah we actually talked about this when
we were starting but that was just too
logistically complicated so uh like
being able to so they basically throw
all the swabs into like one pile uh that
gets put on a truck so if not you'd have
to label them separately based on like
and try to pull them and optimize how
they're fooled and that was just
logistically too challenging so the
contact tracing team would follow up
with all five of those people uh and
that's how they would figure out like
who was tested positive and then they do
their little decision or anything from
there so Dave is those five did other
testing later yes but you didn't learn
versus that was actually the Spanish of
the term in your pool who was a positive
one you now actually change both your
term and your Spanish prior even though
it turned out it was a bad term who got
positive yeah so we get those results
back from the contact tracing team so we
wait for that yeah we wait for that so
you actually okay so you don't okay so
it's not two days later it's five days
later that's part of the delay sorry
that's a great question
um and then finally we have a bunch of
constraints so each point of entry has
like a different arrival makes uh and a
testing budget so I'll talk about that
later so let me just illustrate like
what goes wrong within a batch if you
try to like just do the standard yeah
sorry good
Oh I thought you were gonna see
something
uh within a batch if you try to actually
go ahead with this right so imagine that
you had four types of passengers so for
each one I've gone ahead and computed
the indices Lambda one two three and
four index-based policy will say okay
I'll test the type one passenger so I
allocated test and then like nothing
happens right because like I'm inside my
um algorithm and no one has actually
arrived yet uh and so I'm just I don't
have any updates to my index-based
policy so what's gonna happen is if I
just naively follow this I'm going to
keep testing type 1 passengers until I
run out of type 1 passengers and then I
keep testing type 3 passengers so I'll
over explore like one type or a few
types while I'm waiting to get the
testing results back and you might say
like okay so from a theoretical
perspective this actually doesn't matter
because it takes three days for this
batch to complete right like one day for
the batch to end and two days for me to
get the results back so that's a
three-day DeLay So if you're thinking
about large T time Horizon uh this is
just gonna sort of like disappear right
uh but for us because we're in a highly
non-stationary setting like our data is
only useful in a 14-day window because
every two weeks we discard everything
right so that means that three cases
actually a huge chunk of my effective
time Horizon and so it's not really
feasible for me to keep making like
sub-optimal decisions for so long
so there's kind of this literature on
batch Bandits
um but they typically follow They Don't
Really Work in non-stationary settings
they kind of work in like an explore
then commit type strategy so I uniformly
allocate all my exploration samples to
like a bunch of arms wait for the
feedback to come back and then I commit
to an arm uh but in our setting because
it's so non-station we need to think
about how to weave in Exploration and
exploitation kind of seamlessly within
the same batch right so what we came up
with is something we called a certainty
equivalent updates it's actually very
simple right so the issue is that
um I conducted a bunch of tests on you
know say German Travelers uh and I it's
on some truck somewhere waiting to get
to the lab right uh but unfortunately I
don't have that information yet so it
looks like my estimate is really high
variance so my Bandit keeps wanting to
explore but I know that I'm going to get
a bunch of reduction and uncertainty in
about a day or two right so what we do
instead is they just simulate the
expected reduction and uncertainty so
imagine that you have a beta posterior
with Alpha case successes and beta K
failures and then I allocate a test I'm
going to actually increase my success
and failure by kind of one expected
success and one expected failure so what
this does is it keeps the mean the same
but it reduces the variance by kind of
the information you might expect to get
from one test right uh so we're going to
call these pseudogens indices because
they do dynamically operate wait why
does it keeps the means the same because
you because we normalized it in a way
that it does oh I see yeah because we
haven't gotten any information Nation so
we don't want to change the mean uh but
we do want to like basically say like
okay the variance should go down by like
one effective test
so if this was half success have failure
we would just add like half a success
and half a failure so that the mean
stays the same
um cool so if we go back to this picture
it's actually released full
um I allocate a test to a type 1
passenger I'll do it
up index will go down it will always go
down because the mean is the same but
the variance has reduced right uh and
now my algorithm will actually like move
on to a different type so the nice thing
is that it will allocate basically the
estimated minimum number of tests to
reduce uncertainty for any arms that
have high variance and then all other
tests will kind of go to Arms with high
mean because once the variance is
controlled then the indices kind of stop
changing as much right uh which is
exactly what we want for any branded
algorithm you want to explore and we
want to exploit
uh so here are some actual results from
uh one of the batches that we ran uh so
everything is anonymized because it's
real data but on the x-axis we have like
different types so you can think of
these are country or city identifiers we
rank them from low risk to high risk the
bars show you the number of arrivals and
the teal portion are the number of
people who've been tested so you see
exploitation because everyone gets
tested on this like uh high risk tale uh
but then you see exploration in a sense
that you know like there's a small
number of people being tested in every
bar right so we're doing like
surveillance right
okay that the tourists came from the
low-risk countries that's actually by
Design because the US was blacklisted so
whenever you see one of these big bars
shifting this way they got great listed
or the EU might actually Blacklist them
uh so that was part of what was going on
like you saw Malta was like okay
multi-scopic but like we saw some
countries shifting over we alert their
office of the Prime Minister and they
require negative pistair princess and so
they will come back here
all right
sorry I keep forgetting repeat the
question
um cool so usually people will ask me
why this bar has so many exploration
tests because it is the lowest risk bar
uh but we're still testing most of them
uh and that's because of the constraints
so this is the map of Greece
um so we're not very creative so if it's
a plane it's an airport if it's like an
anchor it's a Seaport and if it's like a
car then it's a lan Port so these are
different points of Entry some of them
are omitted due to privacy national
security reasons
um and the coloring is basically showing
you like how test-rich they are so if
it's like blue it means they're very
test Rich relatively and if they're red
that means they're test four so like it
actually matters where we test people
because some places have more ability to
trust than others relative to their
arrivals and also some people only show
up at some arrivals so Germans probably
yes is like one of the big low risk bars
so they came in huge numbers to All
Points of entry and they were great uh
because they were super low risk the
whole time
but if you look at Northern macedonians
which are MK uh you can see that they
only arrive so here red or orange means
that uh like density uh you can see that
they only arrived to a handful of points
of Entry so that's because they're
coming in through the land ports they're
not coming in as much to the airports or
seaports and so if you want to test in
Northern Macedonian you better save
testing budget like entry 40 or
something like that if you waste all of
that on Germans then you've made bad
decisions because you could have tested
drivens anywhere else
so what do you do okay so like so far
our algorithm is basically saying like
you choose the type with the highest
pseudo-gittens index and you find a
passenger to test but basically what
we're saying now is like you actually
like it matters like where you choose to
test them uh because you might want to
like save tests at certain ports for
like unique types
um and this feels like one of those
online matching problems where you solve
like some big LP uh we didn't know how
to do that with our certainty equivalent
updates uh and we were under a time
constraint so we just went with a simple
greedy heuristic uh which is that we're
just gonna test the passenger of type K
uh if we want to testify Center of type
yeah we just choose someone at the Port
that has the most remaining tests
available you know so if Germans are
coming in at like point of entry one two
and three and three has the most tests
then we'll you know choose test port
three with the hope that you know uh we
save tests at like more constrained
ports for like unique types but I think
there's probably some sort of um
academic thing here about how to
integrate certain equivalent updates
with you know this online matching sort
of problem
uh so the offer them is super simple and
it's very computationally efficient
um basically we get the passenger
manifest at every port so like I know
they're tight passenger ID the port
they're coming to and how many tests are
left uh for each type I compute a
pseudo-bittance index so now I'm going
to say oh type 2 has the highest index
I'm going to test the type 2 passenger
there's two type two passengers showing
up one at Port 143 I'm gonna pick Port
one because it has more tests I cross
this person off I do an update now that
index has gone down so I'm going to test
the type 1 passenger they're only coming
in at four three so good thing I didn't
waste a four three tests that's an
artificially constructed example but you
know you're kind of good and we kind of
run this until we run out of tests
any questions about
cool so the other side of this coin was
like estimating the prevalence uh this
probably goes back to your point of
entry type question uh so a big
challenge here is that we have very
imbalanced outcomes uh so if you kind of
randomly test you know 500 people at the
border only one person will test
positive which is great from a public
health perspective if it's a lot more
than that it would be very irresponsible
to open your borders uh but from a
statistical perspective it is not great
because even though you're testing like
thousands of people every day you're
really only getting like a handful of
positive outcomes so like how do you do
inference with that right and on top of
that the main feature origin though
we're using is like pretty high
dimensional because there's many
different cities people could be coming
from right
um so we actually looked at testing data
like you know 75 of countries had less
than 200 tested passengers in the
previous two weeks uh so that means that
you know let me skip ahead uh that means
that if you wanted to predict zero for
everyone right like if I just predicted
that everyone would not test positive
I'm already getting 99.5 accuracy right
but that's like a useless estimator
because then I'm just like we're all
safe everything's great guys so go for
it
um so that's why I'm in a row like label
the zero line here this is where looking
at excess mean squared error on actual
testing data and we want to beat the
zero estimator right and if you just
kind of did the vanilla estimate of
positives over a total number of tests
you would actually do like much worse
than that because you know there's a lot
of variance here so what we did instead
was to use an empirical based prior to
share information across the different
passenger types so we sort of assumed
that every uh rkft is sampled from a
shared beta distribution like I shared
prior uh and so basically what this does
is if you have very few arrivals from a
particular country you would regularize
that towards a population average if you
have a lot of arrivals and you're able
to get better estimates and then we can
actually get confidence intervals or
credible intervals uh so that we can
actually you know compute these getting
syntheses right uh and that actually
gives us this red dot so out of sample
mean squared error-wise this actually
does pretty well uh it does better than
the zero estimator and then of course
it's like actually useful
verify here so you actually effectively
pull across different countries to
reduce your variance
do you now assume that in the past you
learned that
I don't know the the Spanish Travelers
very much royskis and the French
Travelers do you use it to correct for
that or would you still just pull
naively so we're not we're like assuming
that at The RK of t for each so like our
RK would be like the Spanish mean the
French mean those are sampled from a
shared beta distribution so some of them
will still be higher than others but you
don't want to use uh memory here because
what we saw is like a place would get
really risky and then it would become
much less riskier than other countries
because there's a lot of Behavioral
factors right like if you're spiking
people start acting much more safely and
then you know the risk goes down so like
you wouldn't want to add a constraint
like oh because Spanish Travelers were
safer than French Travelers last week
that that would still continue to hold
right uh but basically the challenge was
just making sure that this had like
sufficient this prior had like
sufficient variance and like I said the
counter factuals we're going to compute
are all based on uh inverse propensity
ratings so they're model agnostics so
there's assumptions we're making here to
kind of reduce the variance of our
estimates to do better out of sample but
um when we evaluate it it's agnostic to
the estimator that we're using
whatever
um cool I'm gonna move ahead ah so
there's like some issues with the type
granularity so like I mentioned
um you know Like An Origin location has
both country and city uh if we did it at
the city level that would be great
because like for example New York City
was a lot riskier than the rest of the
US at this time but then we have you
know like 17 000 arms on our Bandit we
only have 7 500 tests so that would like
quickly uh become super degenerate uh if
we do it at the country level that's
kind of manageable because we only get
about like 160 countries every two weeks
uh but then you know there's some bias
that we're not accounting for the fact
that some places from these high-risk
cities like we're not uh accounting for
that right uh so what we did was we kind
of defined most types of the country
level but we isolated very risky cities
kind of using lasso regression
um so just to illustrate how this works
like let's imagine that this is the us
or something and there are maybe only
seven cities that people came from the
US uh the last two weeks we see that
this blue bar in this new City like
people are testing positive at a much
higher rate and from these other
locations they're all like roughly close
to two or something uh so what we would
do is we would have a lasso of
regression of whether or not people are
testing positive we would throw in
dummies as features for like each City
they could be coming from and then we
just look like you know what gets picked
up in the support
um and typically you know only the blue
one will get picked up everyone else
will be in The Intercept term so that
means we'll Define a new type for New
York City and like everybody else is
like a different type right uh like the
rest of the US
again fake example because us was
blacklisted uh but basically this helps
us trade off this bias and variance like
we want to have City level information
for risky places but um still have a
manageable number of arms yeah but um
would you redo this type meditation
regularly yeah so we read excellent
questions sorry I was too slow sorry
repeat
she asked me so you literally do yes
will we redo the segmentation every uh
every period time period basically so we
read it we read it every week uh because
on one hand we kind of we could have
done it more frequently but like the
policy makers are kind of staring at the
dashboard so we didn't want to like
wildly change the types uh but it was
the case that you know cities that we
would pick up like we picked up a bunch
in France I think like those would
actually change in the non-stationary
way so you do want to update it so
that's what's great about running a
non-station bandit you can constantly
change the arm space and everything's
fine right
great question
is the city data a self-reported yes
everything is actually so reported uh
they go through the customs and so um
the assumptionist people would not lie
um but it is an assumption and I think
there were cases where people did like
and what do you mean by by light that
they would say that they were not
infectious I'm not going to talk about
that while it's being recorded
offline and so they would just misstate
their status right that's what you mean
yeah
some fun stories
the Assumption here is that it's uh
accurately self-reported and we're aware
that you know that's uh I mean I think
that's mostly so so what is self
supported that you are from New York and
not from
well
I'm actually sick of the plane oh no no
the passenger locator form collects the
origin that you're coming from uh and it
is in there isn't like a systematic way
like technically the Customs agent is
supposed to check whether you are
accurately recorded where you're coming
from but that wasn't always feasible so
that is that's what they're talking
about lying my city not because you
don't ask people are your sick problems
you're just asking which city are you
from yeah I mean
the assumptions are not sickles though
but of course they are sick because
they're tested positive but they don't
know that there's so that's not a
feature that we would expect them to
know uh where you're coming from you
should know so you might just report it
um I see so I might know I'm coming from
a very risky City and then I lie about
because I hopes that you protest exactly
yeah
um and like I said when we're doing the
inverse propensity rating like we can
get a valid counter factual but we can't
say anything about how much better one
could have done right so like there's
lots of ways you could have done better
had more accurate feature collection had
more feature collection just add more
tests and be able to do
um uh you know like more accurate
inference of types right so like to
think of this is like a first step but
not you know necessarily like the best
that you could achieve
okay
cool let me get to the evaluation uh so
again we did inverse propensity winning
which is like a really nice way to do
counter factuals because um it's model
agnostic um and the only reason we're
able to do this is because every time a
bandit explores it's basically running
an experiment right and because it's a
non-stationary bandit there's a lot of
Randomness is how it makes allocations
which means the inverse propensity
weights are you know like very well
behaved right
um and so we actually find that uh our
policy gets about an 85 Improvement
compared to random testing which is what
Greece was going to do before in terms
of the number of infections caught at
the border right uh so the steel line
here is basically like what happens if
you did random testing this pink line
here is what happens if you did um like
our policy so the teal line is the
counter factual the pink line is what
actually happened uh and you'll see that
we've segmented it into peak season and
off peak season so in the peak season
we're doing 85 better so just to
contextualize this we used about 7 500
tests a day at the border if we had done
random testing and we wanted to catch
the same number of infections we would
have needed 14 000 tests at the border
which incidentally was like the testing
budget of the entire country so they
wouldn't have been able to do contact
tracing or domestic testing right
um and you'll see that it drops off to
36 percent in off peak season uh and
that's because the Improvement that
we're getting really depends on how many
arrivals are being tested like what
fraction right so um in the peak season
we're getting a ton of arrivals but we
have the same testing budget and so
we're testing about you know maybe 20 of
them and then in the offspeak season
like the arrivals dropped but the
testing budget is the same so we're
testing a lot more people and you can
imagine that any targeted policy is kind
of only useful when you have a limited
testing budget and a limit where I'm
testing 100 of everyone that's coming in
like you don't need to Target all
policies get the same thing right uh and
so we do much better kind of like when
the resource constraint is sort of more
stringent uh anyway see okay like why
are you comparing to random testing
random testing is very attractive
because there's no Financial or
technical investment right you can just
pull random people off of the Customs
line and test them kind of like TSA to
the extent that you believe TSA is
random
um and you know like that's like a very
easy thing to do uh but you can imagine
making a similar financial and Technical
investment uh to do targeting but not
doing reinforcement learning right like
so no Bandit we basically targeted based
on public data metrics so like the
number of cases that were being reported
the number of debts that were being
reported are like positivity metrics
right uh and so what we see is we get
about 25 to 45 Improvement compared to
these metrics and this is where the
censoring shows up so we do like 45
better if it's cases because cases were
highly noisy depending on how much
people were testing in different
countries deaths is less noisy so 37
better than debts uh and then positivity
is great because they actually control
for the number of tests that are being
done so we do only 25 better than
positivity but all of these boosts are
free right so like got the point where
you've already built this infrastructure
you might as well use reinforcement
learning so this is like the value of
the just the better algorithm right
whereas this is the value of you know
doing a lot more work Plus Federal
uh this is technically still an
underestimate in these counter factuals
because behind the scenes there's also a
great listing process going on so if you
imagine what a bandit does is it wastes
a lot of time and budget exploring so
that when you find a high reward arm you
get to exploit it right uh whereas what
we do is when we find a higher reward
arm that's a risky country we tell the
office of the Prime Minister hey like
maybe don't let people from this country
come in anymore especially without a
negative PCR pre-test right so we're
kind of like you know screwing ourselves
over uh but obviously it's like the
responsible thing to do from a public
health perspective uh so if we try to
include that in the counterfactual this
is a much harder counter factual to get
because you can't use propensity
weighting you kind of have to forecast
how much you think people would have
arrived had you not grade listed them
and what their risk would have been if
you try to do this exercise we get about
a little bit over two factor of two
improvements
um based on the 10 countries that were
graylisted by Ava during the summer
um okay do I have time
you still have five minutes okay cool
maybe I'll very briefly say what happens
with public data uh so most countries
through this is elon's question most
countries reported cases debts and
testing rates publicly
um and so we tried to do a very simple
exercise where we use that time series
information to predict whether a country
is risky
um and this is just one possible
classification exercise we did a bunch
but let's say we're interested in
looking at whether or not they have a
risk of more than half a percent chance
of testing positive that's usually when
we started telling the PM like maybe we
should grade list the country so it's
like a policy relevant outcome variable
and you'll see this is like an a uroc
curve and pretty much all the models we
tried had like 0.5 a uroc so they were
complete crop like they didn't have any
predictive power uh and this model five
is like a little bit better it gets a
0.622 Arc which is also not great uh but
basically this one leverages country
specific fixed effects so like I include
the fact that this is UK or this is
Germany in my model you can't learn this
model without actually collecting the
data that we collected so basically this
is just saying that like you couldn't
have done this with just public data uh
to accurately predict what the risk
would be in Greece
um and this is because if you actually
do a scatter plot of this on the x-axis
we're looking at prevalence as measured
at the border from our data on the
y-axis we're looking at new cases per
million as reported by public data you
would imagine that this would be like a
fairly straight line or at least like a
positive correlation because if a
country is riskier in public data you
expect it to be riskier at like our
border but that was like clearly not the
case it's not even clear this thing has
positive correlation
um and there's like a number of reasons
that we hypothesize we don't know the
mechanism but um the testing strategy
typically sensors data so like usually
countries are testing you know high risk
symptomatic patients like older
populations people coming to tourists in
Greece is are not those people uh often
there's also delays and the delays are
country specific so this is an example
of a country that I can't name uh but
you can see that in our lab data despite
you know kind of in the beginning of
August but in public data they didn't
actually Spike until like well later so
there's infrastructure delays in
different parts of the world which means
that they might not actually reflect
when like they're risky until you know
things actually happen uh so case
reports we found were typically delayed
1 to 16 days depending on you know the
country so not accounting for that and
not having information on that uh priori
like obviously also hurts uh your
ability to preserve public health so at
that time of covet how long would it
take to die from
testing positive so did you I mean Aziz
are these long delays essentially now
they're destined you can't deny it
anymore
it could so these they were looking at
cases per capita like when we're looking
at these measurements
um but yeah I think the time to death I
don't remember exactly was about 10 days
or something uh but again that's not the
right population for us because we're
looking the tourist population is very
young and asymptomatic so the death
rates there were very low but yeah
within the country like yeah I'm not
sure
that was a long answer
um but yeah
right right a different death rates
yeah so in the U.S there was also the
attribution issue like what counts as a
coveted death because if you never
tested the patient and they died like
are they really a coveted dad I remember
like Pennsylvania struggled a lot with
the attribution issue and that would
change a lot later so I don't think we
can say yeah
another privilege scale I could guess
what country it is
he got me in trouble
uh so there are other things that you
have out of time but there are other
things that happen your talk is not
different
yeah it's not um I should say the class
on differential privacy
um there were other things that happened
you know in terms of Designing the
testing supply chain like uh that
happened in the background I'm not gonna
talk about it but basically like there
are constraints about like where we
should allocate stopping like where we
felt if we test this is actually used in
our main paper but it's stored up in our
uh applied analytics paper uh there's
different objectives using my
Transportation costs like complexity of
Border operations so like PCR testing
there were dry swab and wet swap PCR
machines and like having both in the
same port like made it difficult to like
collect data so uh depending on the lab
that they were serving like there were a
lot of issues about like main teams like
keeping that complexity kind of under
like wraps uh and also there's this
interesting effect which is that if
you're thinking about allocating tests
and you're looking at the percentage
tested if you're using random testing uh
sorry if you're using something like
reinforcement learning the initial tests
kind of have a higher bank for your buck
right because you're testing like the
riskiest passengers and then as you test
more and more people like the value kind
of diminishes
um but then if you were doing random
testing this would be like a straight
line right so this actually means that
when you're allocating your testing
budget you want to allocate more tests
to places that have very heterogeneous
populations because it's more likely
that you'll be able to get this extra
bank for your buck if you know only
Germans are showing up there then like
probably you're closer to this one right
uh so these are considerations that we
have to do kind of before we actually
even bothered um before we actually
started the system so like imagine that
entry 17 like has like a lot of
heterogeneity then we expect that their
prevalence will kind of have like a
higher tail uh so that means that their
lift over random testing will be much
higher than like entry sixes left over
random testing which means that we
should actually allocate more tests to
entry 17 because we anticipate that
they'll be able to take more advantage
of heterogeneity comparison so did you
do that was actually a question I had
but didn't ask so
as you do your testing you might
actually say you know what we might we
need more tests and assets did you do
that you couldn't do that we tried
really hard to do that but uh these are
like fairly significant financial
contracts and Staffing is like also a
big logistical problem so they were very
unwilling to actually change that during
the course of the summer so it's a
One-Shot decision and
obviously leaves money on the table but
it was not something we were able to
budge them on
um but yeah so then there was like some
like dashboard work about trying to
visualize the trade-offs between you
know like the number of infections we
could catch versus like the complexity
of this testing supply chain and so we
would show them like different plots and
you know generally they prefer less
complex so that they can actually follow
up on these things you know um and you
know ensure that things are actually
going smoothly uh so there's like I
think in any of these policy projects
some work to be done on like being able
to visualize things that are like
generally hard to quantify or visualize
right uh like if you just show that if
you just tell them like oh that's the
complexity of the network they don't get
it but if you show this plot like it
kind of makes more sense
um and that's it I think there's a lot
of exciting opportunities to use these
kinds of tools to improve lives like uh
we're doing some work with uh uh Sierra
Leone and DRC to try to improve National
Distribution of Health Products uh and
also working with law enforcement to
identify human trafficking cases from
Deep Web data using kind of similar
tools uh which we're pretty excited
about and I'm happy to talk about online
[Applause]
okay I think we had a lot of questions
so let's
go okay okay
so so thank you I mean this was really
really a fascinating presentation and I
must say that that it made me think
about some of the the work that you know
my group has done at Ohio State in the
context of testing students these are
different types of tests because we were
doing continuous testing so we were
retesting populations but basically the
following question and the comment you
know in general the types of problems
that you're looking at these are
so-called it seems like these are
stochastic markovian optimization
problem because you're assuming that you
don't have memory you have some kind of
Markov process that you're following you
have some time of emission probability
meaning you will you're not observing
the actual state but you're observing a
surrogate and that basically gives you a
way of making inference about the hidden
variables so so they're basically two
elements to this the one is called
hidden Markov models which is a very
well known area that's studied in
engineering community but there's also
this General more general theory related
which is called the dynamical
programming and it goes to something
which is called elements optimality
principle which in the stochastic
setting roughly speaking means that from
step to step you can build up a maximum
likelihood estimator in some sense under
constraints right so just just out of
curiosity are these the types of so so
how would some of these solutions that
you have here compare to just straight
application of this Belmont optimality
principles in the markovian setting so
the guidance index is actually the
solution of a a dynamic program like
using Bowman's operator I think usually
the issue is that uh typically these
problems you have full feedback whereas
we have Bandit feedback right so you
don't actually get to see like whether
or not someone is testing positive
unless you actually test them so that's
what the guidance index literature is
sort of on uh and it turns out these
Dynamic programs in the presence of
Bandit feedback are highly
computationally intractable which is why
people came up with these kind of um you
know simpler heuristics like Opera
conference Brown and Thompson sampling
that have like using is uh asymptotic
like low regret guarantees uh so we're
sort of but that's exactly why we tried
to build on the gitens index policy
because you know it has some like
optimality notion yeah right directors
so I think that's uh that's really
interesting that that you can do this
sort of in you know in a sensible way
computationally right because this is
always oh we want to take any credit for
that that's getting thing but yes I
think that was kind of a big so thank
you yeah thanks
foreign
see you all back